the san antonio spurs coach greg
popovich
he just said one of the dumbest things i
think that i've ever heard i can't
believe how much sports i have to watch
these days
i'm not the biggest sports guy i don't
think i'm shocking anybody when i say
that i the only sport i like is baseball
and when they went woke last year i
canceled my subscription
i but now i've got i got to watch
football because of gruden i've got to
watch basketball because of this guy
popovich greg popovich seems to believe
that if you
honor christopher columbus who some of
us honored this week
that that's that's no different than a
german celebrating hitler
indigenous people's day
columbus day
columbus
i mean he initiated
a new world genocide
that's what he did he took slaves
uh he he mutilated he murdered
and
we're gonna they're gonna say slash and
honor it's columbus day that's why
they're off
on monday
you know maybe there's something i'm
missing and i'm ignorant
but it makes me feel like they're living
in a phone booth and they're educating
our kids
columbus day
and we're going to honor that
and it's
it's no knock on italian americans
that's a silly argument
you know it's like saying we should be
proud of hitler because we're german
i mean it makes no sense it's about
columbus it's not about italian
americans
so there's one thing that this guy said
that was true which is maybe i'm
ignorant and maybe i don't know anything
yeah i don't i think he is probably
ignorant and i think he probably spent
most of his school years dribbling and
that's perfectly fine that's that's his
job in his career but he clearly didn't
pay a lot of attention in history class
i'm not going to rehash the arguments
over columbus columbus was a great guy
who did a lot of great things notably
bringing christianity to the western
hemisphere he's accused of doing a lot
of things that he never did and by the
way for a lot of the indigenous peoples
that were here their culture wasn't all
that great to begin with notably the
cannibalism and the human sacrifice some
some people were good people
to to invoke the former president some i
suppose were good people but uh but
columbus was far less bad
and far more good than people give him
credit for and the indigenous peoples
had some pretty horrifying demonic
practices that that columbus and the
spaniards who came after him put an end
to rightly so
but notice the angle here
the angle is this celebrating columbus
if you're an italian is like a german
celebrating hitler which means that
columbus and hitler are the same person
they're comparable and
because
you got the italian people you got the
german people and they're both admiring
these guys and so these guys are
comparable right
that that's the argument but it's not
true it's ridiculous it's this new angle
to say that the the person christopher
columbus who is responsible for bringing
our civilization to the new world is
evil
right the embodiment in many ways of
western civilization
is
evil meaning the civilization itself is
evil and when we when we talk about all
these radical theorists who developed
this stuff i know sometimes people are
skeptical and they say michael how on
earth does some radical marxist in his
ivory tower at harvard university you're
telling me that that guy because he
wrote some ridiculous book that no one
has ever really read that is affecting
our whole culture yes it does have
downstream effects in our culture even
to the point that this ignorant
basketball coach
is spouting the lies being pushed by
radical academics and polemicists
including in this case someone like
howard zinn
who who is a revisionist
historian he's not even really an
historian he's a political activist it
does have effects all the way down the
line
the left has taken its once in a
generation opportunities every time they
pop up over every single generation and
they've used it to great political
effect and we have not and that's to our
disadvantage
columbus is like hitler give me a break
i'm so glad that you liked that show
make sure you subscribe to the michael
knowles show here on youtube ring that
bell but also maybe more importantly
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play
and type in the michael knowles show and
click subscribe and that's it and then
you'll get the full unvarnished opinion
that hopefully doesn't get censored like
some places we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you